does the United States need to launch a
commercial war is the US economy in
danger due to the high trade deficit
that they carry with them each and every
year it's China competing in an unfair
way and how can Donald Trump defend the
United States
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I'm not saying they're stupid
I'd like China I sell apartment 4/10 I
just sold an apartment for 15 million
dollars to somebody from China am I
supposed to dislike but we can't
continuously have other nations taking
advantage of the United States like
never before the biggest bank in the
world is from China for many years
no president wanted to go against China
economically and we're going to do it
because we can't continue to allow China
to rape our country and that's what
they're doing in particular with China
we're gonna be doing a section 301 trade
action it could be about 60 billion
dollars but that's really just a
fraction of what we're talking about
dear viewer intentions are certainly one
thing and results well that's entirely
another that's precisely what almost
always happens with protectionist
policies they're aimed at doing one
thing but they end up doing something
totally different
Donald Trump was very clear about this
during the election campaign that led
him to the White House and he has
continued to be just as clear since he's
arrived in the Oval Office protectionist
policies are a fantastic idea
I want those companies and they're
starting I want them back here I want
them back here they're gonna come back
here to Trump signs new tariffs on steel
and aluminum into law
Trump moves to crack down on China trade
with 60 billion in tariffs on imported
products Trump proposes 100 billion
dollars in additional tariffs on Chinese
products so far only the first tariffs
have been approved such as those on
steel and an aluminium and it excludes
many US allied countries for that steel
and aluminum
your country's not the same but
according to the news Trump is very very
clear about one thing and that one of
his main priorities is fighting the
external deficits that is reducing the
difference between imports and exports
this is a difference of over 500 billion
dollars every yea
[Music]
and that is where tariffs always come
into play it goes something like this so
my people they want to buy foreign
products fine tariffs will teach them
about that all right all right hold on
let's let's be fair
[Music]
many argue that Trump doesn't really
want to get involved in a full-blown
commercial warned that the u.s.
president's threats especially against
China are nothing more than a gamble to
force Xi Jinping's government into
sitting and negotiating and yeah that
might be so but since one never really
knows with Trump just in case and to
clear things up I think we need to ask
ourselves a few important questions does
it help the United States open fire and
trigger a trade war our tariffs really
the best way to help the US economy is
China breaking the rules are they
competing in an unfair way and do we
need to punish Beijing well let's see
Wall Street took a hit today that knew
the news of the terrorists from China
took it pretty hard
China's Ministry of Commerce says it is
imposing tariffs on 128 American
products sold in China China announced a
15 percent tariff on u.s. fruit wine
steel pipes and other products this is
in response to Trump administration
tariffs on aluminum and steel imports
from China and other countries
a bad plan for a non-existent problem
folks here is a question what does a
politician want when he puts
protectionist policies on the table and
no no I know what you're thinking and
I'm not going to accept winning votes as
a valid answer yes look I know winning
votes is every politician's number one
priority but for that very reason let's
not cheat let's focus on the specifics
of protectionist policies well I think
we could say that the objectives are
usually this defending industrial jobs
punishing alleged unfair competition
usually by poorer countries and boosting
the local economy
[Music]
[Applause]
now those are the intentions but what
are the results if the United States
starts a trade war with China is it
going to achieve those objectives well
let's have a look at this step-by-step
first of all this is what Donald Trump
has to say on the matter
under my administration the theft of
American prosperity will end we're gonna
defend our industry and create a level
playing field for the American worker
Donald J Trump Wow
thank goodness that politicians are here
to defend the American people by the way
this is absolutely the same excuse he
uses to prosecute immigration defending
that American worker but there is only
one problem and to be fair it's really
big problem and that is that these
statistics show a completely different
situation
you see the US labor market is
undergoing one of the best moments in
almost two decades the unemployment rate
is at about four percent and the number
of unfilled vacancies is growing
enormously indeed the American economic
machine is actually beginning to suffer
shortages of one of its most important
inputs and that's of course labor if
migration policies do not change and the
economy doesn't collapse of course it is
estimated that in the next ten years for
the United States will have more than
eight million jobs to be filled
[Music]
and this is actually happening quite
intensely in the Midwest in states like
Wisconsin where there's a lot of
employment but very few workers it's
great to have more people working in
Wisconsin than ever before but it
creates a challenge we just essentially
need more people tricia braun chief
operating officer for the Wisconsin
Economic Development Corporation right
now unemployment rates in those states
are below 3% and new jobs are constantly
emerging for example the Taiwanese
technology group Foxconn is investing
more than 10 billion dollars in a
gigantic campus to develop and produce
new smartphones tablets and television
screens it's going to employ more than
13 thousand people the situation is so
peculiar that state authorities have
been forced to launch an advertising
campaign for example on trains in
Chicago and indeed here on YouTube in
order to attract workers to their state
but not only that you see the truth is
that the manufacturing industry now
employs a lot fewer people than it did
two decades ago but do you think this is
actually due to Chinese competition well
the reality is the numbers tell quite a
different story not only is employment
at its highest levels in US economic
history industrial production has also
reached its highest levels yes the
industry hires fewer people but that
doesn't mean it produces any less what's
happening is that factories thanks to
robots and technology are becoming
increasingly productive
so how about an example of this let's
take a look at the steel industry which
Trump said is being threatened by
Chinese competition indeed he has stated
that this poses a danger to national
security well the truth is that the US
produces 70 percent of the steel it
consumes for which only 3% is actually
intended for military use so him saying
national security leads me to the reply
really and on top of that China it's not
even in the top 10 suppliers yeah
employment in the steel industry has
decreased to almost half in the last 10
years but folks the vast majority of
jobs aren't lost due to China or
international trade but simply due to
technology and look a commercial war
it's not gonna change that but as you
can probably see this isn't precisely
bad nowadays in the United States there
are more jobs than ever and the trade
deficits well despite what Trump might
say it isn't really that high being less
than 3% of the GDP and in fact it has
decreased considerably in recent years
we're also really forgetting some other
important details like for example the
investments yeah you heard that right
the United States has a positive net
investment balance that is foreigners
invest more in the United States than
Americans do abroad which is obviously
very good for the US economy's future in
2017 this positive balance surpassed 250
billion dollars anything that's all well
you are very very wrong now we don't
know if a commercial war would decrease
the external deficit but it would have
other not exactly desirable consequences
so well listen up to this
[Music]
the consequences so let me say it loud
and let me say it clear the ones who'd
be most affected by a trade war against
Chinese imports would be US companies
yes you heard that right I did not screw
it up buying cheaper materials abroad
decreases production costs for local
industries and in addition a foreign
country in this case China sells below
cost it would be like Beijing with
subsidizing American industries alright
so this point you might be thinking well
this sounds really good but is it
actually right well take a look at this
now we need to bear in mind that the
United States not only imports products
to consume from China they also import
many intermediate goods and capital
goods such as machinery in fact more
than half of all imports from China
corresponds to this type of products
so now comes an essential question what
with the tariffs actually achieve
well it's precisely that it would damage
American companies competitiveness
that is it would increase the cost of
producing much more advanced Goods and
aspect in which the North American
industry is currently a leader
this would mean decreasing their exports
to the rest of the world as well as the
consumption capacity of Americans
themselves and the result of this
well that's millions of jobs being
destroyed for example the new tariffs on
steel and aluminium will make production
in the United States of things that use
steel and aluminium like cars and
airplanes more expensive and therefore
less competitive so well new tariffs
have to be set on cars in order to
offset this higher local production cost
and this TIFIA
explains why when in 2002 president
george w bush imposed tariffs on
imported steel the toll was the
destruction of 200,000 jobs this was a
clear backfire of the intended policy
but there is another really important
detail yeah when you set tariffs the
usual reaction is for the other party to
defend itself I'm not saying it's the
right thing to do but well it does
happen the United States announces an
additional 100 billion dollar list of
tariffs China has already fully prepared
and will not hesitate to immediately
make a fierce counter-strike gal fang
china's commerce ministry spokesman all
right so let us use the example of
boeing china is the largest market today
for this company and in the next few
years is going to deliver hundreds of
new aircrafts to china well a commercial
war would absolutely damage their
long-term competitive position china for
example could favour other companies
such as airbus and accelerate the
development of a local industry yes it
does seem difficult today but in the
long term the consequences could be
absolutely gigantic
[Music]
and that's not even to say that China
could resort to other less Orthodox
means for example let us not forget that
China is the largest foreign debt owner
for the United States but it'd be good
for Washington if China stopped buying
debt or if they began decreasing
securities in order to incite pressure
well these are pretty obvious questions
the answer is definitely no this is
especially due to the huge public
deficit that the current administration
is fueling but wait just a moment
because there is something that Trump is
absolutely right about
[Music]
is China breaking the rules
Donald Trump has one thing right China
isn't precisely a free-market or a
country that plays well with others and
it isn't just about the fact that they
have high tariffs or that they favor
local companies the rollin is for
example blackmailing large
multinationals for example if foreign
companies want to sell freely in China
they have to ally with local partners
partners who can access their technology
and oh yes this technology transfer is a
problem in some ways because these
Chinese companies then use this
technology to grow and compete
however technological companies know
what they're getting themselves into
when they access the Chinese market it
has to be them who decide where to
produce how to compete and what
businesses to get involved in of course
this doesn't mean that the US government
shouldn't pressure or negotiate with
China but unleashing a commercial war
would be a terribly bad solution so
listen as long as it's just threats the
US they're gonna be alright but they
have to be careful not to cross the
light this is how a big crisis would
start
fortunately unless Trump insists it
really looks like this isn't gonna
happen
China initiates WTO dispute complaint
against US tariffs on steel and aluminum
products President Xi Jinping announces
plans to open up China's economy
including lowering tariffs for autos and
enforcing the legal intellectual
property of foreign firms now having
said all of this let's just wait a
moment because there is still a question
on the table and that's how can the
United States reduce its trade deficits
well the best way to achieve this is
with bets with structural policies doing
what great exporting powers like Germany
and Switzerland it favors saving and
therefore long term productive
investment decreases the public deficit
which boosts import consumption by over
eating the economy and improves the
competitiveness of local businesses
for instance reducing bureaucracy
favoring talent attraction yes
immigration and lowering taxes as the
last fiscal reform of the Republican
Party did which we talked about in a
previous video those are the paths that
should be taken while a commercial war
that's gonna be just bad for everyone
and in any case external deficit doesn't
have to be bad it all depends on how
much the economy grows what it is used
for or what happens with the investments
well now over to you do you favor
setting tariffs on China well let us
know your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoyed the video please do hit
that like button if you did and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine and as always thank
you for watching Wall Street took a hit
today that knew the news of the
terrorists from China took it pretty
hard
China's Ministry of Commerce says it is
imposing tariffs on 128 American
products sold in China
[Music]